patient data at your fingertips done at
the Saint Lucas hospital in North
rhine-westphalia doctors have direct
access to digital files including the
results of all examinations become you
will get the results right on my iPad so
it's quick huge nila that is if
everything works earlier this year the
hospital's computer system was infected
by a virus called Tesla crypt or locky
experts at software security group
Kaspersky Lab know this problem Tesla
crypt ransomware is something they deal
with on a regular basis the desert also
filthy when this ransomware enters a
computer it encrypts the users files you
then get a message think the data is
still there but cannot be accessed
unless you pay a fee even small towns
like dead labeouf in bavaria have been
victims of ransomware the Town Hall paid
the ransom as mine um I know nah I think
it was a mistake into thinking because
we shouldn't let ourselves be
blackmailed it's nothing Thornton
imagine if everyone got away with it
won't turn into a banana republic with
honorable Budig law enforcement experts
agree that paying ransom is the wrong
way to respond on the mute it encourages
repeat offenses and makes the
blackmailers greevey we should avoid
this at all costs waiting for might'n
cyber crime is on the rise security
engineers spot 300,000 malware programs
per day how do we took what this is Mike
nugget of the Digital Underground has
become its own business sector it offers
a variety of services there are
providers of malware that is
pre-configured or upgradable for a price
it's like buying a car hold the bar
spids5 Saint Lucas paid no ransom the
hospital shut down its computers and
restored files from a backup staff will
now get further training mon cala DZ
hide all you can do is increase
securities initially he was the oh so
cool as far as the consequences are
concerned we're definitely more
vulnerable today than we used to be if
our IT system stops working and
assignments it's a bit like driverless
cars a lot of people like the idea but
imagine what would happen if the whole
thing breaks down from sunni request on
Posse encoder the computers are up and
running again at Saint Lucas and no data
was lost doctors armed with tablets are
once again making the rounds